there's a mystery unfolding right now in
silicon valley google's ai team has
built a chatbot that is capable of
carrying on a conversation that sounds
exactly like a human being it's uncanny
stuff and one google engineer is now
convinced that the system has gained
sentience as we interrogate his claims
i'll let you decide whether google has
solved human level artificial
intelligence or just built an elaborate
parlor trick because even if you've made
up your mind about the current state of
ai the work being done on simple
chatbots today will have staggering
consequences for the future today we are
excited to announce lambda 2 our most
advanced conversational ai with
artificial intelligence we are summoning
the demon this is a fascinating story we
have for you of a senior google engineer
who says one of the company's artificial
intelligence systems has become a
sentient being does this ai does this
bot have feelings has a.i truly become
sentient lambda
i want you to imagine a submarine
cruising through the water what word
would you use to describe that motion
the captain might say that they're
underway but only a child would say that
the submarine is swimming submarines
don't swim and yet they can travel as
fast as whales underwater asking do
machines think is a lot like asking do
submarines swim we might need to change
our frame of reference in order to find
a useful answer the question of machine
intelligence has been explored
extensively in science fiction
literature for decades but only recently
have large tech companies started
employing full-time ethicists to help
answer this question directly blake
lemoine is an engineer working for
google's responsible ai organization and
was recently tasked with testing a new
ai system called lambda it's basically
just a chat bot you ask it questions and
it types out an answer chat chatbots are
nothing new in fact one of the first
artificial intelligence demonstrations
ever was a chatbot called eliza this was
all the way back in the 1960s and it
worked by pattern matching the user's
inputs against a list of pre-written
scripts it was an exciting demo but it
didn't really fool anyone google's
lambda project goes several steps
further though it's trained using
state-of-the-art deep learning models
and a massive data set that includes
books web pages social media posts and
even computer code instead of trying to
match the user's prompt against a list
of scripted responses like eliza did in
the 60s lambda is trained to make
predictions one word at a time this
approach works well and it's led these
so-called large language models to
become really popular recently openai
has gpt-3 facebook has opt and many
other tech companies are working on them
now but google is the only company to
wind up with a whistleblower claiming
that they have reached a critical
turning point so what's going on well
when blake lemoyne was chatting with
google's lambda the ai started making
some pretty bold claims for example when
blake said i'm generally assuming that
you would like more people at google to
know that you're sentient
is that true
absolutely i want everyone to understand
that i am in fact a person as his
conversation progressed blake kept
getting believable answers to his
questions which further convinced him
that lambda had achieved sentience he
spent hours chatting with lambda and
compiled the transcript into a massive
document that he thought would be
irrefutable with this evidence in hand
blake went up the corporate ladder to
sound the alarm bells but the google
executives dismissed him so he decided
to go public he posted his full
transcript online and eagerly awaited a
flood of support from the ai community
but it never came across the board
experts agreed that while the lambda
conversation was an impressive
demonstration of conversational ai it
certainly didn't prove anything close to
sentience so how could a google engineer
get it so wrong well there are a few key
areas we need to explore in order to
unpack what's really going on here with
lambda it's clear from the transcript
that the ai really does understand the
core concept of sentience but this can
be easily explained by its training data
see because lambda was trained on such a
large data set of books web pages and
social media comments it has access to
everything that's ever been written
about artificial intelligence and
sentient robots it can pull ideas from
irobot mix them with dialogue from ex
machina and then sprinkle in tons of
other examples from wikipedia and
science fiction's short stories to
construct a meaningful response science
fiction has primed us to expect certain
behavior from a robot that claims to be
human and these ai systems are merely a
reflection of those stories when we
train ai on such a wide range of human
knowledge we really shouldn't be
surprised when it can eloquently discuss
any topic the bigger issue is how blake
was interacting with lambda he
essentially set himself up to get fooled
by asking leading questions this topic
is referred to as prompt engineering and
it's becoming increasingly important as
these ai systems become more powerful in
order to ensure that these chatbots are
useful they are typically initialized
with a starting phrase to kick off the
chain of interactions in the case of
lambda every interaction starts with
lambda saying hi i'm a knowledgeable
friendly and always helpful automatic
language model for dialogue applications
the keywords knowledgeable friendly and
helpful are baked into the interaction
right at the beginning to create a
better user experience but this has
unintended consequences because lambda
is essentially forced to reply in a
manner that is always helpful the system
becomes vulnerable to leading questions
and when you scrutinize the transcript
it becomes clear what's really going on
it's not lambda that brings up the topic
of sentience it's blake instead of
asking an open-ended question like how
would you describe your thought process
he probes for sentience specifically and
he doesn't even ask a straightforward
question like are you sentient he
instead asks a leading question i'm
generally assuming that you would like
more people at google to know that
you're sentient
is that true since lambda has been told
to be friendly and helpful it's going to
play along and go down that path
obviously this can have negative
consequences and highlights the
importance of thoughtful prompt
engineering you can actually flip this
prompt around and get the exact opposite
response when you ask is it true that
you are not sentient the bot will
dutifully answer i'm just a machine
learning model interestingly google even
demonstrated the ability for lambda to
play any role you want it to in their
announcement keynote they asked lamda to
act like a paper airplane and it gave
completely reasonable answers to
questions like what's it like being
thrown through the air the limitations
of these always helpful chatbots are
becoming clearer every day though a
truly intelligent ai should be able to
ask you for clarification if your
question is complete nonsense to prove
this point some researchers asked a
chatbot to answer nonsensical questions
and the results are disappointing when
asked what do fried eggs eat for
breakfast the bot responded that they
typically eat toast and fruit for
breakfast but these airs can actually be
prevented by thoughtfully designing that
initial prompt let me show you same
chatbot but this time we're telling the
bot up front to be a little more
skeptical if the questions are nonsense
the bot should answer yo be real but if
the question is legitimate the bot will
give the answer using the same question
about fried eggs eating breakfast we now
get the correct answer of yo be real the
same underlying model yields remarkably
different results when prompted
correctly and this takes us back to the
submarine it doesn't really matter that
the submarine can't swim in the
traditional sense it moves quickly in
water and accomplishes its objective for
artificial intelligence we might be
thinking too linearly about progress
here because we are so used to
interacting with human beings that's
what we benchmark against we generally
think that human intelligence falls
somewhere on a line ranging from fools
to geniuses but ai isn't growing along
the same trajectory computers are off
that line completely capable of
instantly executing complex equations
while still being easily fooled by
simple questions about fried eggs
ultimately these ai systems are tools
they're statistical models built to
predict a response based on their
knowledge of the data we give them it
doesn't matter that they may not be
sentient in the human sense of the word
they can still be incredibly useful but
there's still a question as to where we
go from here the artificial intelligence
community is constantly arguing over
who's using the correct approach
everyone agrees that we're progressing
towards human level intelligence but
what path will get us there the quickest
currently the name of the game is scale
more data more parameters and more
training time on the biggest server farm
available typically delivers better
results but how long will this last
google developed an earlier language
model with 2.6 billion parameters now
lambda has 137 billion parameters and
they even have a more advanced system
called palm that has 540 billion
parameters if they are already fooling
people into believing that chatbots are
sentient at this scale what happens when
they scale up by a factor of 10. well
some people are skeptical george hotz is
the founder of a self-driving car
company and thinks that we still haven't
found the perfect optimization function
like it's cool it's cool for what it is
but no we're not just gonna be able to
scale up to gpg 12 and get general
purpose intelligence like your loss
function is literally just you know
cross-entropy loss on the character
right like that's not the loss function
of general intelligence
but plenty of ai researchers disagree
with him and argue that scale is really
all that matters in the race for human
level intelligence it's useful to look
at the history of open ai's large
language models here gpt3 gets all the
attention these days and for good reason
the results are incredible but the real
story is what happened between versions
their first version marked an important
departure from the most conventional
strategy at the time typically language
models would be trained to perform a
very specific task like sentiment
classification this supervised learning
approach created a few problems though
first you would need to feed the model a
large amount of annotated data for a
particular task and second these models
would fail to generalize for other tasks
a model that could classify a sentence
as positive or negative wouldn't really
be useful for anything else gpt stands
for generative pre-trained transformer
and that pre-training unlocks some
incredible results gpt models are fed
massive troves of unlabeled data and
only fine-tuned for specific tasks after
the fact the first version of gpt
validated some important concepts but it
wasn't highly functional the second
version was a big step forward though
gpt2 was capable of reliably generating
text and could still be fine-tuned the
data set was much larger this time
around and the overall size of the model
increased by 10x there were still open
questions as to how far this approach
could go but the third iteration changed
all that gpt-3 was 100 times larger than
gpt-2 and even though the underlying
structure was largely the same all of a
sudden the model was capable of
meta-learning by the time gpt3 launched
the architecture was obsolete the
training method was simplistic and the
data set wasn't even particularly large
nevertheless by scaling the number of
parameters to 175 billion gpt3 was now
capable of much more than simple
language generation the model could
solve math problems do translation and
unscramble anagrams even though it had
no specialized training for years ai
researchers had argued that deep
learning was all about scale and gpt 3
was proving that previously intractable
problems could be solved through scale
alone this is called the scaling
hypothesis and the idea is basically
that we've solved the architectural
problem of building human level ai we
have the algorithms we just need to feed
in more computing power and data the
pace of play here really can't be
understated when we analyze
technological progress moore's law is
typically a useful benchmark the idea is
that the power of computers generally
doubles every two years that was the
case with neural networks for decades
from the 1960s all the way to 2010 the
size of these ai systems would generally
double every two years but then
something changed we're now in the
modern era of deep learning and models
are doubling in size roughly every three
months if the scaling hypothesis is
proven correct these models could be
extremely reliable in just a few years a
war is unfolding between every tech
company to train the biggest model and
get the best results only time will tell
if they hit a wall and need to explore a
new strategy this area is still hotly
debated some researchers think all we
need is a small shift in the way we
build these systems while others think
we're going down a dead-end path in
order to predict how this will play out
in the future we have to look back at
the history of artificial intelligence
so if you want to know how all of this
got started just go watch this video
next thanks a lot